this is the last image the Spitzer
transmitted back to earth the tarantula
nebula named after the filaments of gas
that resembles spiders legs stretched
out to cross the cosmos it is one of the
telescope's first observation targets
when it was launched sixteen years ago
Spitzer allowed us to again look at
things lift the cosmic veil and see
these supermassive black holes that we
couldn't see previously since then that
has revealed twice as many galaxies as
any other Observatory and most
importantly perhaps advanced human
knowledge of black holes and the birth
and death of stars spitz's operational
life was expected to be five years at
the most
but even after its helium fuel ran out
the telescope continued to send vital
data about the universe back to earth
its relatively small size led scientists
to label spitzer the little telescope
that could so this is an image of the
telescope and I also have a little model
of it right here in front of me now so
this is 1/32 the size of Spitzer so if
you if you multiply this little model by
32 times you'll come up with a
spacecraft that is about 13 feet in
height it weighed nine hundred and
thirty kilograms approximately at launch
and it was this small telescope that
identified another solar system similar
in many ways to ours the Trappist one
system a dwarf star 39 light years from
Earth surrounded by seven exoplanets
some of which showed traces of water and
which scientists agree may contain
life-forms remarkable nature of the
Trappist one system discovery got that
science onto like mainstream media at a
level that that had really very seldom
seen out of asset now the command has
been sent to the spacecraft
switching it to what is called safe mode
and in about 53 years it will come back
past the earth and then head away in
another direction into space even though
spitzer is
what you would think of is a hibernation
mode folks don't like you to say
hibernate believe me it was really hard
to come up with a term that everyone
agreed on based on the final state right
there that we're beyond but the legacy
of spirit sir will live long because the
data is there for people to go back in
mind the legacy of Spitzer is 16 years
of data archived at a u.s. University
data that may still produce new
discoveries about ourselves and our
universe Mike Hanna al Jazeera
Washington